Paul last time you were with us you told
me that every one of the movies you make
makes money when sharknado was this
runaway success last year not just on
social media but ultimately and its
limited release in theaters was it a
no-brainer that sharknado 2 was coming
this summer yeah it was a no-brainer in
fact almost within a couple of days
after a sharknado came out we had the
go-ahead from sci-fi to make the sequel
they've even greenlit two sharknado 3 so
we'll be talking again next year I hope
oh my goodness me describe for me the
thought process that went into sharknado
2 sharknado 2 the original was a bizarre
enough concept as it was write a tornado
filled with killer great whites arriving
in Los Angeles this one's in New York
City how did you get there
well you know sci-fi has always wanted
to base a film they're based in New York
and they've always wanted a base of film
there and it really was a no-brainer
that we destroyed the West Coast in the
first film we destroy the East Coast in
the second one okay we know that as I
mentioned sharknado the original was a
massive success given the fact that it
was such a low-budget film to begin with
how well did that do financially and how
much better then were the terms for you
for sharknado 2 well I would love to be
able to tell you that I'm soaking in
bathtubs of money from sharknado but the
truth is it performed about the same as
our other films relative to the budget
however the benefit that came from
sharknado in addition to sharknado 2 and
sharknado 3 is also the fact that the
sci-fi channel has greenlit a series for
us and most importantly for me
personally is that for the first time
ever in my career if somebody asks me if
they've heard of anything I've made the
answer is yes sharknado
how do you translate the sort of
phenomenal quality of the original
sharknado 2 this one we're talking about
it that clearly helps I'm sure you're
talking to other people about it too
but what really lit up for sharknado was
this unanticipated social media response
is there any way to ensure that you get
that kind of reaction again I don't
think there's any way that you can
ensure it you know I really believe that
social media had a big impact on
sharknado lightning only strikes once in
other words yeah that's true but I think
that the awareness of this film gives us
a very good chance of repeating history
so much of what made sharknado appealing
was not just the bizarre crazy plot
which is kind of standard fare for
asylum but the this sort of what I guess
the Williamsburg hipsters would call the
ironic quality the sort of c-list
quality to the movie this time around a
you're trying to do it as a sequel
there's no telling whether it'll you'll
pull it off the same way you did with
the original but also you've got an iPad
app is it if they're not the possibility
here that is kind of too much of a good
thing yeah there's always that risk but
I can say that and I've seen the film
and there's no more no one more cynical
about our movies than me
but it's it's better than the first it
is a non-stop roller coaster ride and I
think that if people tuned in out of
interest they're gonna stay because it's
a great film better is an interesting
way to describe the difference between
the first film in the second film I've
seen the trailer first sharknado 2 I
guess you have to be lurking for certain
things to call it better at Paul
sharknado 3 where is that going to be
set we haven't decided yet but since
sharknado 2 which was is supposed to
take place in the summer and we filmed
it in February in New York during a
blizzard we're all hoping that we can
place it somewhere very warm